god I'm dressed like the Fonz with the
[ __ ] Impractical Jokers the movie so
Impractical Jokers the movie is a movie
based off of Impractical Jokers to show
kind of I mean half of it is anyway
gonna kind of recap what the show is
won't take long for guys Joe Murr Sal
and Q they've been friends for life and
it's a hidden camera prank show one
person will be out there they have to do
a task or interact with people in a
certain way yeah this movie will be
hidden but they can see them on a
monitor and they have a microphone
they're talking to him in an earpiece
and that person has to say or do
whatever they tell them to do they're
always coming up with new scenarios and
new logistics it's a remarkably
entertaining show it reliably makes me
laugh and I like myself a good reliable
laugh show cracks me up so now there's
an Impractical Jokers movie and it's
tough that okay what I liked about the
movie is when the movie is being
Impractical Jokers to show you know with
them who fee is being what Impractical
Jokers fans are coming to see
Impractical Jokers tough man on the
street interaction they have to say or
do some really cringe-worthy [ __ ] I like
that because it shows that the movie
knows what the fans want obviously
they're coming to see what they're
familiar with what they know the show to
be and I like the four guys I like Joe Q
Sal and Mirage I think they're they're
charismatic and they're likeable cuz
their pranks they're never hateful you
know they're never malicious they're you
never feel like they're dicks and I
enjoy that about the show and I like
seeing that in the movie there were
these challenges I was laughing
sometimes I got a good laugh sometimes I
got a great laugh sometimes it fell flat
not everything lands with the challenges
in the movie just like the show I never
had a laugh as hard as that first Jaden
Smith tattoo in the show oh my god I
couldn't breathe it was hysterical but
all in all I enjoyed the Impractical
Jokers element as it was happening then
there's the other half of the movie so
the movie it has a plot back in 1992 the
Impractical Jokers crash - Paula Abdul
concert yes Paula Abdul plays Paula
Abdul in his movie so now they have to
make a Paula Abdul concert in Miami
Florida so it's a road trip movie these
four guys are doing a road trip from
Staten Island New York to Miami Florida
and along the way they make pit stops
and they do Impractical Jokers
challenges and that element just didn't
work for me at all
it's not a very engaging road trip movie
all the roadtrip stuff that whole
narrative is it's all scripted [ __ ]
it knows it is it doesn't try to hide
it's not like it's like now it's real
know what's the plot of a movie carrying
itself out like a movie but not so
engaging kind of bad movie and every
minute that scripted roadtrip storylines
happening I was like this is another
minute we could be concentrating on
Impractical Jokers challenges you know
what people came to the movie for I mean
no one ever liked Impractical Jokers
because it was a scripted roadtrip story
because it's not been that ever which
granted if you look at it bad grandpa
did that same thing it was a road trip
movie plots and which among this road
trip they'd make stops and then hidden
camera pranks however in the way of bad
grandpa felt like the way it was filmed
and executed the way it went from
roadtrip movie to pranking people with
hidden cameras the scripted element and
the hidden camera elements that they
felt like they were supposed to be in
the same movie in this movie the road
trip element the dialogue the way it's
filmed the way it looks in contrast to
the hidden camera challenges it feels
like two different things
this kind of takes you out of it it
doesn't feel like the same movie which
is a bummer because this Impractical
Jokers movie is just a victim of when
they wanted to release a movie most
shows like this can get a movie after
the show's done and people can't watch
the show anymore though we want more
Impractical Jokers great here's a move
but as I understand it the show is still
going on so if you just watched a series
of challenges you'd be like why wouldn't
I just watch this at home which is fair
though I would have totally preferred an
hour and a half or two hours of just
Impractical Jokers challenges if that's
the only place to see those challenges
well then you know supply and demand but
I suppose they could release Impractical
Jokers if it was like all right well
it's uncut though we can show you some
stuff we can't show you in the TV show
but it's a pg-13 movie they never do
that I never saw anything in this movie
that I wouldn't have seen in the show so
I really feel like I don't know for sure
but I really feel like they just had
these challenges and punishments banked
and they were like we don't know what to
do with this alright let's write a
crappy roadtrip movie and throw them in
there it's apart of me to think so they
wanted to do this because they wanted to
flex their acting talent you know maybe
they want to move past Impractical
Jokers being scripted movies or TV shows
maybe this is a way to beef up the
resume I get it Hollywood it's it's a
tough world operate in now here to judge
that I understand that element I'm just
talking about the movie as for the movie
I felt like the tones just clash
you know I don't think I've ever done
this before but here's how I'm doing it
now here's how I'm writing it for the
half of this movie that was actually
Impractical Jokers with challenges like
we know from the show say it was a good
time no alcohol required the roadtrip
movie element but I really did not care
about not gonna remember that in t-minus
one day yep already forgot in the end
you do walk out of the movie feeling
like I could just stay home and watch
Impractical Jokers from home all right
so the Impractical Jokers movie or the
show have you seen the movie do you
watch the show what do you think about
him whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more so
Impractical Jokers the movie is a movie
kind of based off a pregnant that was
like this is another minute weak you
suck dog hair fluttering around and
every minute that scripted wrote yeah
[ __ ] danger you shed too much in the
winter